gérald darmanin ne s'attendait pas à une
telle riposte après ses propos
qualifiant la garde des sceaux de tracts
ambulants pour le fn le député du nord
c'est d'abord attiré les foudres du
premier ministre hier alors je vous le
dis monsieur norman a les yeux dans les
yeux ça n'est ni la jeunesse ni la
campagne électorale ni le combat
politique qui doit vous permettre de
tenir de tels propos et nous ne
permettrons jamais on signe de soutien
les députés ps ont offert une
standing-ovation à christiane taubira la
cible préférée de l'opposition qui n'a
besoin de personne pour se défendre elle
considère les attaques du jeune député
comme rien de moins que des déchets de
la pensée humaine ce matin à la sortie
du conseil des ministres
elle a ajouté une salve franchement je
trouverais pitoyable malgré son jeune
âge peut-être même du fait de son jeune
âge sans doute à cause de la
déliquescence de son parti l'on soit
contraire à s'exprimer à tenir des
propos qu'ils ne soient pas hitler
éclairé par un idéal républicain pour
moi je trouverais ça pitoyable si
j'aurais de la pitié a gaspillé pour
ceux des élus de droite sont venus au
secours de leur collègue christian jacob
estime que les déclarations de
christiane taubira sont ignobles et dans
un tweet xavier bertrand juge que ces
propos ne sont pas digne d'un ministre
de son côté gérald darmanin persiste et
signe et a reçu le soutien unanime de
tous sont partis dans un communiqué
publié par l'ump